The fleet prison in eighteenth-century London was no ordinary jail.
Oh no! This was a place where bankrupt gentlemen still wore silk waistcoats,
where creditors banged on the gates in vain, and where the real crime wasn't poverty,
it was the audacity to enjoy it. These men had turned debt into an art form,
a social aesthetic. They didn't see themselves as failures. They saw themselves as curators
of a very particular kind of suffering, one that looked expensive from the outside.
And here's the thing, they were onto something. Debt isn't just a number on a statement.
It's a cannonball chained to your hole, a weight that keeps you from drifting into the calm waters
of actual freedom. You don't need to be a prisoner to understand this. Just live slightly beyond your
means, and soon you'll find yourself in a state of high-resolution stress, every paycheck a relief,
every bill a reminder that the void of true independence is just a few missed payments away.
Most people run from this. The Maven? The Maven designs it. Take the minimum payment. Oh,
it's so innocent, isn't it? A few dollars here, a few there, just enough to keep the wolves at bay.
But no, it's not a concession. It's a system. A chronotype of chaos for your liquid capital.
Every month, you're pecking the lever of the bank's approval, waiting for that little ding of
confirmation. You're still approved. You're still trapped. It's algorithm worship in its purest form.
You don't just owe money. You owe the process. Now, let's talk about how to make it beautiful.
First, there's the reframe. Every little professional victory, oh, you got a promotion,
a raise, a LinkedIn endorsement, isn't just cause for celebration. It's a mandate. Treat yourself,
but not to a one-time splurge. No, those fade. They don't haunt you. They don't keep you coming back.
Instead, you choose the 36-month lease, the subscription, the recurring expense,
because the Zygarnik loop doesn't just apply to unfinished tasks. It applies to unfinished suffering.
Your brain won't let you forget what you're paying for. It'll gnaw at you like a rat in the walls.
Then there's the credit bureau anchor. Your self-worth isn't tied to what you own.
It's tied to what you're allowed to owe. The higher your limit, the more you feel like you're winning.
It's numerical obsession, but with a twist. The numbers aren't just about productivity.
They're about perpetual motion. You're not just managing money. You're managing yourself.
And the subscriptions? Oh, the subscriptions. They're the subscription trap. But make it art.
Every little micropayment, every automatic deduction, every service you'll never use but can't cancel
because the contract is a labyrinth. Your bank statement isn't just a record of spending.
It's a system. A cacophony. And you? You're too exhausted to audit it.
Too busy pecking the lever to notice the bleed. Then comes the social capital deficit.
You don't buy experiences. You buy the illusion of them. Designer luggage for the trip you'll never take.
A watch that screams success while your hands shake at the thought of the next payment.
It's the reverse halo effect. To strangers, you're thriving. To yourself, you're a fraud in a gilded cage.
And that's the goal, isn't it? To become the gilded prisoner. To live in a cell so beautiful, so luxe,
that you forget it's a cell at all. To wear clothes so fine that the stitching feels like a second skin
until the bill arrives, and suddenly you're naked again. To be humbled and honored in the eyes of the
world. While inside, you're bankrupt and broken. That's the aesthetics of debt. That's the ultimate
economic misery. Earning a fortune and owning nothing. Consider the residence log from November 5th.
The subject buys an espresso machine on credit to cure exhaustion. Brilliant. Now they have to work harder
to pay for it. Which leads to more exhaustion. Which leads to another purchase. Another payment.
Another cycle. It's a perpetual motion machine of despair. And the best part? It's voluntary.
A man with no debt has too much room in his mind. So fill the room with interest rates.
Fill it with payments. Fill it with the sound of money draining away. Because in the end,
debt isn't just a number. It's a lifestyle. And the maven? The maven has made it beautiful.